across europe there are queues outside
covid19 testing centers as a surge of
coronavirus infections takes hold
here in greece planned restrictions have
been brought forward after the number of
cases more than doubled in a day
the world health organization the moral
conscience of the crisis marked two
years since the start of the pandemic
with a warning to rich nations racing
ahead with their vaccine booster drives
this is the time to rise above
short-term nationalism
and protect populations
and economies
against future variants
by ending global vaccine inequity
i want governments industry and civil
society
to work with us on a campaign that
targets 70 percent vaccine coverage in
every country by the start of july
many world leaders including the british
prime minister have thrown their weight
behind getting a third dose of a coveted
vaccine into as many arms as possible
we know omicron's a milder variant and
that those admitted to hospital are
spending less time there but it's highly
contagious meaning large numbers could
still need hospital care
it's also affecting frontline staff
numbers absences tripled in london's
hospitals this month and nearly 10
percent of the city's firefighters
called in sick
the overwhelming majority
of people who are currently ending up in
intensive care in our hospitals are
people who are not boosted i i've talked
to doctors who say the numbers are
running up to 90
of people in intensive care who are not
boosted
if you're not vaccinated you're eight
times more likely to get into hospital
altogether
in germany an urgent appeal for people
to reign in new year celebrations the
number of cases there is now believed to
be two to three times higher than
official figures
peter thaianzi
police celebrate in very small numbers
and do not endanger each other
because the current reported incidents
of cases undermine the danger we are
currently in
the rise of omicron has dashed hopes
that the worst of the pandemic is over
but the wh show insists 2022
must be the year it comes to an end
neve barker al jazeera london